[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show really not
great news from the pennsylvania primary
race for u.s senate john fetterman who
is not only the front-runner but the guy
i like and i think would bring a great
presence to the u.s senate
he has suffered a stroke but says he's
on his way to a full recovery
the primary is tomorrow
and yesterday it was announced that he's
recovering after a stroke
and um
there are not an unlimited amount of
details but we know that it was a stroke
caused by a clot from his heart being in
an afib rhythm for too long
he's feeling better doctors tell him he
suffered no cognitive damage and that
he's on his way to a full recovery
our campaign isn't slowing down one bit
he says we're still on track to win this
primary on tuesday and flip the senate
seat in november he was on his way to an
event in fact on friday when his wife
said you've got to get checked out at a
hospital he wasn't feeling well went to
the hospital didn't want to go didn't
think he had to go his wife insisted she
was correct
and um
this is so so you know a few different
things first of all you never want to
hear about anybody
having an illness that prevents them
from doing what they want to do whether
it's go to work or raise a kid or run a
campaign and and that's terrible and our
thoughts are with john fetterman in
terms of the impact on the race
if this was
imagine that this was the final
the the final election that this was
november and it was you know oz versus
john fetterman
and it was close
this is the type of news that might
dissuade some people from voting for
john fetterman on the idea that he's not
healthy enough to do it my opinion here
pat is that because this is the primary
and his lead seems to be so significant
on the democratic side that this won't
have an impact and assuming he stays
healthy between now and the primary up
between now and the general it will also
not have an impact then that's my
feeling right now i have the same sense
as you and yeah excellent to hear that
he's doing better now no cognitive
issues or long lasting effects from the
stroke so that's all well and good i'm
sure he'll win tomorrow's primary i do
wonder if maybe it will become an issue
in the general election because we talk
so much about you know candidates age
uh ages are they too old to run for this
office or that office fetterman's only
52 years old so he's certainly not old
enough but maybe a candidate like a dr
oz could make the case that well maybe
he's just not healthy enough and can you
guarantee that he's going to be able to
serve out his term for six years given
that he just had a stroke i don't know
if the candidates would be so willing to
stoop to that level but let's say
they're behind in the polls just a
little bit going into election day maybe
that's something that they will bring up
and it could potentially persuade enough
voters not to vote for him it's expected
to be a close election in november in
pennsylvania yes so this may be the
difference who knows i would not put it
past republicans to try to use this
and um
if indeed
this is as as we are being told and he's
going to be fine i would find it to be
below the belt to make that case as we
approach november but listen first he's
got to win the primary and that's
tomorrow and we will we will be watching
the results not only from the democratic
primary but also from from the
republican primary
in terms of the by the way
have you been following pat what's going
on in the republican primary in this
race i heard there's like a new
up-and-coming candidate that's maybe
taking away some of the attention from
member oz but you can probably explain
it better than i can so kathy barnett i
i hate to do it this way but
there's two women who are running
there's
carla sanz and kathy barnett carla sans
is the white woman and kathy barnett is
the black woman who talked about being
black during the debate she made it a
thing
she apparently now is having a surge
where the so-called ultra magga people
are kind of like we already didn't like
oz
and mccormick isn't appealing to us very
much
we're gonna get behind kathy barnett and
i i don't think this is appearing to be
enough to actually get her to win
tomorrow in the primary but she is
gaining in the polls and people are
talking about it like she's the way to
go now well it could be enough to tip
the balances right because if the manga
people are split between barnett and oz
true of course maybe barnett is more in
line with trump on the policies and the
rhetoric but oz did get trump's
endorsement after all then maybe
mccormick who i believe is still in
second place he's not anymore i just
learned in an average of recent polls
barnett is now in second place within
one point of mccormick so they're
technically like tied within the margin
of error but technically she's slightly
ahead so are we going into tomorrow
thinking that this is anyone's race on
the republican side is it still expected
to be oz but maybe there'll be an upset
like what should we be thinking here oz
is plus three so anyone's race it sounds
like it's kind of anyone's race yeah
this this may be the and what's crazy is
not to pat ourselves on the back we said
this would be one of the most
interesting and consequential races
early on
yep and uh just like how i was rooting
rooting for josh mandel in the ohio
primary just because that would make
trump upset right to get a loss on his
endorsement record i have to root
against mem at oz because not only do i
think that he'd be stronger than any of
these other republican candidates in a
general election in pennsylvania because
of his name recognition and sort of like
centrist positions on things you gotta
also root against him because that will
deliver trump yet another loss
absolutely absolutely triggered by that
so yeah i mean mccormick barnett i guess
i'd prefer mccormick because worse comes
to worst if uh we do get a republican
out of this race i'd rather be mccormick
than a crazy person after all uh but as
long as oz doesn't win tomorrow i'll be
happy that's gonna be quite a race to
watch and my if they're my expectation
is there will be live results coming in
and if that's the case i will be
streaming
mitch mcconnell the senate minority
leader says that the senate is going to
pass the largest ukraine aid package yet
on wednesday
this is going to be a 40 billion dollar
aid package mcconnell says he supports
adding russia to the list of state
sponsors of terrorism and would hold a
vote on it but said that joe biden
should do it on his own
he was in stockholm and mcconnell also
said he supports finland and sweden
joining nato in which they've expressed
interest so this is one of those stories
pat where the big story is the russian
invasion of ukraine and how long is it
going to go
a secondary story is american funding
for ukraine and then the third story is
the possibility of new entrants into
nato and altogether
this is kind of a a growing story
finland and sweden joining nato would be
a major deal and it would be exactly
what russia has been saying would be
considered an act of aggression in
addition to that there are more people
on the left and right although we could
question what that really means in this
context but there are more people who
identify as being on the left and right
expressing growing skepticism about the
amount of money that is being invested
in supporting ukraine often citing
things like you know inflation gas
prices baby formula although there are
kind of questions as to exactly how all
of that ties together but needless to
say
more and more people aren't as thrilled
as they were about some of the money
that's going to ukraine right and some
time has passed as well like when this
all started i feel like a lot of people
were gung-ho
uh supporting ukraine saying we want
funding for them so they can fight off
the russian invasion now it's been a
couple of months and so people's
interests tend to wane and so yeah maybe
you have less support towards an aid
package going to ukraine republicans can
say things like why are we spending 40
billion dollars over there when we have
problems here we got to deal with
immigration and the left can say
a similar thing right why are we
spending 40 billion in ukraine when we
can focus on health care and education
and homelessness and that sort of thing
and it really doesn't have to be an
either or like you can solve a lot of
issues certainly we have the resources
to do it but we just don't allocate it
all that well and also you can look at
us spending money in ukraine as sort of
an insurance policy because if ukraine
is able to
ward off the russian attacks i think
they're we're much more likely to see
russia not want to go into some of these
other countries maybe a nato country
sure like if they were able to easily
take over ukraine we'd probably be
talking about okay which country are
they considering next going into is it
going to be a nato country or we're
going to be at a full-fledged war with
them at some point obviously that would
be tremendously costly so just for
insurance purposes if we can make it so
we stop russian advances here and now
while we still can then that avoids us
getting you know billions of dollars
into the whole trillions of dollars into
the whole even in the future so i
support the funding myself there's a
degree i think to which
people generally in the us still
sympathize with the ukrainian cause here
but because as you say of how long it's
been going on
you can sympathize with the cause just
as much as before
but not necessarily feel as though there
needs to be new money going there and i
think that that's kind of what's
happening to some people it's sort of
like the fatigue of we understand it
hasn't changed but there's less of a
beginning middle end we're getting into
this kind of like protracted indefinite
middle
and as we know with other news stories
when you have no clear end in sight of
the story
people start to in a way tune out or at
least be less interested in using money
to try to solve a problem yeah and it's
like we're now focused on the new issue
like the media cycle this year so far at
the beginning of the year it was very
much uncovered because of the omicron
surge yeah then that kind of went away
obviously the russian invasion of
ukraine took over in the media that was
the dominant narrative then we had this
leaked decision
from the supreme court having to deal
with roe versus wade potentially getting
overturned so people's focus turned to
abortion rights now we had this mass
shooting so that's going to take a part
of the news and you can only pay
attention to so many things at once
right and so you're gonna pay attention
to the new thing uh and something that
drags on for months and years it's just
not going to get the same attention so
that's just sadly part of our character
as a people like that's just how people
operate i suppose and uh we have to in
some cases fight through it still make
sure that people are aware of the
updates and uh get people the news that
matters even though it's been going on
for a little while yep and we will see
what if and when there is a catalyst
that reshapes the story
into one where people are saying this is
the number one thing we've got to send
money we've got to support because right
now interest in that does uh does seem
to be waning
hey here is a um
an interesting story we already talked
about how elon musk's purchase of
twitter is on hold and for a while now
i've been saying i don't think it will
ever happen elon musk tweeted
on saturday that twitter's legal team
accused him of violating a
non-disclosure agreement by revealing
that when twitter checks for bots they
use a sample size of 100 so let me
explain the whole backstory
elon musk said the reason that the
purchase of twitter is on hold is
because he's concerned he's not getting
accurate data about what percentage of
the site's users or automated bots or
accounts fine
um
he later when then that became
controversial
he tweeted
well we
were told by twitter that they pick a
random hundred users to come up with the
k the claim that under five percent of
the accounts are fake spam or duplicate
accounts and elon musk apparently
doesn't necessarily think that that's
enough but he says they're going to do
the same thing and when people said well
why are you using only 100 and he said
that's what twitter does twitter's legal
team is saying that they told him that
as part of an nda and that he's now
violated an nda now i whatever the legal
thing is i mean like sue him do whatever
the hell you want
to me 100 does not seem to be an even
remotely appropriate sample size with so
many different types of accounts on
twitter individual accounts of people
that have no public presence people that
have a public presence organizational
accounts trolls bots automated reposting
all these different things
it seems difficult to me
that a statistician would look at this
and say that a hundred is going to give
you a representative sample i i just i
just don't think it does
yeah so maybe go with a thousand or ten
thousand yes this just strikes me as
maybe elon trying to back out of the
deal because remember when he offered to
pay out the shareholders and buy the
company he said okay i'm going to offer
you 54 dollars and 20 cents and that's
my last best uh final offer i don't want
to play games with negotiating and that
sort of thing that's exactly what he's
doing right now right he's trying to
negotiate he's trying to get that price
lower because he's trying to argue well
if a lot of these accounts are bots then
the company isn't as valuable as you
claimed it was which may be true but
it's certainly not this like thing where
he just wants to buy it no matter what
he doesn't care about the details yeah
um and you know a few weeks when we were
talking about this uh
when you said like oh i think it has
like a 50 50 chance of actually
happening do you remember what the odds
were about that i i mean i think i
probably said 50 50. although i don't
remember i thought it was 90 10 where he
had a 90 percent chance of taking it
over and 10 percent oh no not taking it
over but i'm going to stick by that i'm
just going to say that well if this
doesn't work out it was the 10
yeah you got the 10 number that was
always the thing about predictions where
it's like people misunderstand what we
mean by a prediction right so sometimes
they'll say well the polls said that it
was an 88 chance that hillary would win
and she didn't so the polls were wrong
and it's like well no the the result was
in the 12 and when we talk about a
confidence and you know these terms have
very specific meaning in statistics
and uh anyway i know most of the
audience gets that i get that what
you're saying is a joke but yes it would
just be you it was still 90 10 it just
might be that the 10 is what went out
yeah well i love it because in this case
it benefits me i get to say that i was
still right nonetheless even though i
did say it only had a 10 chance but we
don't know yet for sure like maybe he
will end up taking this thing over or
maybe he's just playing with all of us
he knows that this will get the media's
attention people will be talking about
it it'll stir controversy for a little
bit he loves doing that sort of thing
too so i wouldn't be surprised if that's
his goal with all this on the
statistical thing the there's also the
reverse misunderstanding where sometimes
you'll say to someone no there's like a
98 chance that this is going to happen
and they'll go no listen there's two
possible outcomes it does or it doesn't
it's 50 50.
and then you have to explain well what
we mean by 98 is if you ran a simulation
with these inputs 100 times
98 of the times this would be the
outcome 98 of the times it would be this
outcome and two of the times it would be
this outcome they go no but either it'll
happen or it won't it's 50 50.
i've been in some of those conversations
and they can be extraordinarily
frustrating
yeah that just doesn't stand up to basic
logic right because like you could say
well there's the possibility possibility
of an elephant appearing in this room
right now at this very moment sure
there's also a possibility that it
doesn't appear in this room at any
moment so that's 50 50 as well no one
would argue okay well yeah there's a
99.99
chance that the elephant doesn't appear
in the room but both situations are
possible so
for some reason people can sort of
rationalize how in an instance like that
it's not 50 50 but these other things
like who's going to win an election
who's going to win a game in sports that
sort of thing you don't think of it the
same way the other one would be like i
think a good way to illustrate would be
this would be okay listen
imagine that you have
uh a bunch of uh you have dice you have
a hundred dice
and
the dice only have one number on them
right it's it's a six-sided die but it
only has one number on it and the number
is either one or it's six and i'm gonna
take a bucket and i'm gonna put in dice
that have a one on them and dice that
have a six on them so there's really
only two options right it's either a one
or a six but
of the hundred dice
99 of them are gonna have a six
and one of them is going to have a one
most people when you explain that would
go okay even though the two options are
a six and a one i understand it's not 50
50 because 99 of the dice have a six on
them i think for the average person that
does help to illustrate this concept
right and maybe when you're talking
about elections or sports or whatever
the case may be then people's emotions
are at stake because they want to see a
particular outcome whereas they don't
care about the outcome of the dice roll
so definitely there's some logical
fallacies playing into it the the reason
why we can't always understand these
statistical scenarios no doubt about it
no doubt about it um for people who
asked i may be covering the so-called
ufo hearing tomorrow there's actually a
hearing tomorrow involving the i believe
it's the pentagon
on unexplained aerial phenomena some are
calling them ufos i have a hectic day
tomorrow but i'm going to try to cover
at least some of it so join me then and
we'll see everybody tomorrow